et s'il vous reste un brin d'enfance
vous allez sans doute apprécié big fish
le dernier film de tim burton le
réalisateur notamment de batman signe là
une oeuvre imprégné de merveilleux et de
fantaisie avec une petite touche de
poésie parce qu'elle défend patrick voit
tel un monsieur loyal
tim burton fait deux nouveaux jaillir de
l'écran un de ces univers plein de
fantaisie dont il a le secret il nous
attache cette fois on pas des douars
bloom un drôle de père de famille
racontant l'histoire de la vie de mon
père il est impossible de séparer la
réalité de la fiction car port édouard
blum
la vie est un véritable roman depuis le
récit que banal de sa naissance il n'a
cessé de raconter à son fils des
histoires s'inventant des aventures
incroyables embellissant chaque épisode
de son existence comme par exemple sa
demande en mariage à une jeune inconnue
rencontrée dans la rue
mais jeudi
ce sont vos fleurs préfet vous en avez
vous trouvé au tout j'ai appelé tous les
fleuristes dans cinq états je leur ai
dit que c'était la seule façon de
convaincre ma femme de mes cousines
tennis et j'ai toute la vie pour se
connaître
je joue edward blood jeunes donc un
personnage pas vraiment réel comme on en
trouve beaucoup dans l'oeuvre de
sundance un personnage plus grand que la
vie comme on dit à john wayne j'ai cru à
des histoires plus longtemps que je ne
l'aï su quand je me suis rendu compte
que tout ce que tu me racontait était
impossible je me suis sentie idiot
d'avoir cru tu es comme le père noël les
cloches de pâques une charmante
imposture moi je m'identifie opère bien
sûr car je crois que l'on peut vraiment
s'enrichir grâce à son imagination
tous les enfants ont ce don mais quand
ils grandissent ils deviennent des
adultes sérieux
alors disons que oui je m'accroche à ma
part d'enfance tim burton ne pouvait
qu'être sensible au destin de cet homme
qui sentant sa mort prochaine veut
simplement laissé à son fils la petite
part de rêve qui a nourri toute sa vie